it's a privilege for us to present the
final award of the evening the films we
honor tonight inspired us touched our
emotions gave us hope and joy and may
even have changed our thinking well I
think that it could be said that our
goal in politics is the same as our goal
in art and that's to get to the truth so
that's like in the movies we honor
tonight that not only entertain us and
move us they show us the increasing
diversity in our community and a respect
for diversity and freedom all over the
world ok let's get to the movie ok so
here are the nominees for Best Picture
[Applause]
and the Academy Award for Best Picture
la-la land
[Applause]
Wallace has 14 Oscar nominations this
year and it's tied for the most
nominated movies in Oscar history
winning seven Oscars production design
cinematography Original Score song
directing actress and Best Picture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you all thank you to the
Academy thank you to Lionsgate thank you
to our incredible cast and crew we're
all up here right now thank you to Jamie
Sullivan to Gary Gilbert thank you to my
parents for supporting my choice to
pursue a career in the arts even though
it was a little bit crazy
Arthur Horowitz you are my fantasy baby
and to my kind generous talented
beautiful blue-eyed wife and creative
partners Julia Hart who you have
inspired me to become the man I am right
now and more importantly the man I'm
still becoming there's a lot of love in
this room and let's use it to create and
champion bold and diverse work work that
inspires us towards joy towards hope and
towards empathy here's to the fool who
made me dream my uncle Gary Platts my
mentor Sam cone my parents my children
my wife Julie on whose shoulders I've
stood for 40 years because she insisted
I reach for the stars and to the
Hollywood community that I'm so proud to
be a part of and as a Hollywood in the
hearts and minds of people everywhere
repression is the enemy of civilization
so keep dreaming because the dreams we
dream today will provide the love the
compassion and the humanity that will
narrate the stories of our lives
tomorrow
the love of my life allele Oh am I here
because of you I was it so much my
family memo by Jeff homage was dead dull
matte fluff you kicked this off and
Damien Chazelle we're standing on your
shoulder we lost by the way but you know
I'm sorry no there's a mistake moonlight
you guys won best picture is not a joke
I'm afraid they read the wrong thing
this is not a joke moonlight is won Best
Picture moonlight Best Picture
I'd like to keep it anyway
guys
very unfortunate what happened
personally I blame Steve Harvey for this
I would like to see you get an Oscar
anyway why can't we just give out a
whole bunch of oh I'm going to be really
proud to hand this to my friends for
moonlight that's nice
hello hello hi I want Lauren what did
you do I want to tell you what happened
I opened the envelope and it said Emma
Stone lala land that's why I took such a
long look at Fey and at you I wasn't
trying to be funny
well you were funny now thank you very
much
thank you very much wow this is this is
new night the best picture yeah
um
thank you very clearly very clearly even
in my dreams this could not be true but
the helmet dreams I'm done with it
because this is true oh my goodness
thank you thank you and I have to say
and it is true it's not fake we've been
on the road what these guys were so long
and that was so gracious and so generous
with them my love to lala land my love
to everybody man thanks thank you
I don't know what to say that was really
it I'm not sure I so much sure this is
real but thank you to the Academy and it
is so humbling to be standing up here
with hopefully still the Lola curtain oh
okay they're gone but it's very humbling
to be up here and I think I hope even
more than that that it's inspiring to
people little little black boys and
brown girls and other folks watching at
home who feel marginalized and
take some inspiration from seeing this
beautiful group of artists found by this
amazing talent my friend Barry Jenkins
standing up here on the stage accepting
his top honor yeah there was a time when
I thought this movie was impossible
because I couldn't I couldn't bring it
to fruition I couldn't bring myself to
tell another story
so everybody behind me on the stage said
no that is not acceptable so I just want
to thank everybody up there behind me
everybody out there in that room because
we didn't do this you guys chose us
thank you for the choice I appreciate it
much love goodnight thank you so much
[Applause]